from SpaceX to neuralink the enigmatic
Elon Musk has been part of some of the
world's most notable inventions however
you cannot deny that the company he's
most synonymous with is Tesla with the
energy Revolution happening in the world
right now Tesla has chosen to be at the
Forefront revolutionizing transport with
their electric cars solar panels and now
electric yacht if you've not been living
under a rock you've probably heard of
Tesla where there is a random mention in
a conversation as part of a Twitter
conversation or is the name of the
famous inventor Nikola Tesla from where
the company gets its name Tesla was
created in 2003 by two men Martin
Eberhard and Mark tarp Henning however
in 2008 during the company's series a
funding Elon Musk gave the company 6.5
million dollars effectively making him
the largest shareholder in the company
and chairman of the board of directors
Tesla is arguably one of the most
popular brands and their market cap of
more than 600 billion is a testament to
that fact it also helped that their
owner Elon Musk is swelled an
interesting character to say the least
but I didn't come to talk about Elon
Musk or the market capitalization of
Tesla today what brought me here is
Tesla's super yacht idea this concept
popping up isn't really surprising
because as you can see in this video
Tesla can Cruise a flooded tunnel with
no problem at all Elon even commented on
the video we deaf don't recommend this
but Model S floats well enough to turn
it into a boat for short periods of time
thrust via wheel rotation and also in
2020 he said a Tesla works as a boat for
short periods of time as an electric car
has no intake or exhauster block and
Battery Slash motor slash electronics
are water sealed submarines are just
underwater EVS so at the very least we
can infer that the concept of a water
vehicle is in his mind that's right
Tesla is spreading its wings and
entering the ocean and Open Seas for
this futuristic company ocean
exploration only seems like the next
logical step and this yacht would become
one of the world's first electric
self-sustaining yacht model y now I want
you to close your eyes and imagine
cruising on a yacht that never needs
fuel one that has an adjustable interior
that can be expanded or contracted at
the touch of a button a Sleek design and
a futuristic Spa where you can relax as
you Cruise across the Seven Seas ever
since the first teas in 2017 Tesla has
been keeping us on the edge of our seats
with its highly anticipated super yacht
which was rumored to have a jaw-dropping
price tag of 700 million dollars but
wait we're already in the 2020s so where
is this super yacht speculation is that
the super yacht will be powered by a
combination of solar and hydroelectric
power making it self-sufficient and
environmentally friendly essentially
this powerful machine would draw power
from the skies and seas so what can we
expect from this luxurious vessel the
self-charging model Y super yacht will
be a whopping 40 meters long
approximately 131 feet long from an
aerial view you can see that this yacht
is built like a squid a smart idea to
make the vehicle both futuristic
practical and streamlined despite its
massive appearance the model Y Yacht
will only have two decks two bedrooms
and a Jacuzzi with the lower deck being
an open space perfect for throwing
massive parties and if that's not enough
there will also be a spacious Spa dining
room and cabins designing concept
vehicles for Tesla is not new and that's
understandable given that in just 11
years Tesla has become the top electric
car selling company in the world
surpassing many established and trusted
car and tech companies the exterior of
the boat was heavily influenced by Tesla
superchargers combining beautiful strips
of red stark white and gray on a mix of
sharp and curved lines also the name
seems to be derived from that of the
Tesla Model Y which completed the four
Tesla car models called sexy cars the
model S model 3 Model X and model y Elon
Musk sure is a fan of creative names
from his car to his kids now back to the
yacht content there are only two decks
aboard the yacht but those two decks
have some elements you won't find
anywhere else the top deck boasts a bar
and dancing area covered by a massive
roof with hundreds of LED lights that
glow at night upon reaching the upper
deck of the yacht you'll discover the
glass room where the real excitement
occurs the Glass Room boasts panoramic
glass walls that provide a 360 degree
view of the water below overhead the
ceiling features numerous tiny Windows
creating a mosaic of skylights that
resembles an art installation as you
step inside you'll notice a sunken bar
on the right which gives you the
impression of being aboard a spaceship
even though this is a Tesla yacht not a
SpaceX spaceship the stools at the bar
are made of a unique material that can
be shaped into any form you desire
enabling you to adjust them to your
liking whether you want them taller
shorter or more supportive this material
is present throughout the upper deck
including in the central Lounge area
providing both a fantastic party trick
and a comfortable place to relax and
enjoy the stunning views trippy right
this yacht has a back shutter door that
can be lowered at the touch of a button
to turn the outdoor deck into an indoor
Jacuzzi or pool room it's perfect for
when those winds are too strong or you
find yourself in an annoying weather of
any kind plus the shutter door features
the coveted Tesla logo making it even
cooler inside the yacht you can expect a
circular bar a lounge suite and two beds
the ship's lower deck consists mainly of
one large living area at first glance
the living area seems only to have
curved seats against a window that looks
out over the ocean but there are tables
in the middle of the room at the touch
of a button the tables spin out
providing four chairs each for people to
dine drink work or relax and when not in
use they can be tucked away to provide
room for whatever activities you have in
mind a true ergonomic Marvel in the back
corner of the living area two rooms are
located in curved glass the spa room is
equipped with two massage tables and
while it may not be the most secluded
area for massages it is still in elegant
space the rim boasts beautiful patterns
textures and colors with vertical and
horizontal hardwood flooring the window
area is adorned with curved lines
providing guests with a prime relaxing
spot the ceilings are finished with a
glossy black texture and sharp diagonal
lines adding to the luxurious Ambiance
however the rims highlight is a stunning
peacock wall that stands out boldly
although to be honest it seems unlikely
that Elon Musk would choose this
striking feature the outer regions of
the room including the ceiling are
illuminated with LED lights that emit a
modern and inviting Aura further
enhancing the room's lines next we have
the Captain's Room this room features a
control panel but this isn't your
conventional yacht because their designs
don't appear to show a physical wheel
you can use so no pretending you're a
pirate or anything though there are no
photos of the bedrooms there should be a
captain's bedroom off the Captain's Room
now let's take a look at the other sides
of this marvelous water vehicle the back
of the yacht has a small deck that sits
very low against the water this area is
a perfect launch point for water sports
or even scuba diving a ladder is also
located off the back providing easy
access in and out of the ocean for those
on board who prefer to relax the back
deck features a lounging area as well as
a space for a pool or jacuzzi this is
the perfect spot to enjoy the sun and
the Beautiful surroundings of exotic
locations but what truly sets this yacht
apart is its electric engine and
self-sustaining capabilities at the very
top of the ship there will be a solar
panel that charges two lithium batteries
at the same time a turbine will work at
the bottom of the hull to turn waves
into energy that can power the yacht in
any situation where solar energy isn't
enough this way the hybrid renewable
energy model featuring the onboard
battery and solar panel will ensure that
the yacht will never run out of charge
while the yacht is in motion or when the
boat is docked and not in motion overall
the Tesla Model Y Yacht is a concept
that has gained a lot of attention and
is down to change the way people think
about luxury yacht this luxurious
vehicle is not only cool but it also has
a lot of the amenities you could dream
of with the added benefit of being
completely silent the sharp and Sleek
exterior and spacious interior the model
yacht embodies Tesla's principles and
outside the box strategy regarding
performance the model Y Yacht will be
lightning fast and Incredibly
comfortable this yacht is a testament to
Tesla's commitment to Innovation
sustainability and the ability to apply
principles in exciting areas and who
knows maybe one day we'll see the Tesla
Model Y Yacht sailing the Seven Seas
these renders of the yacht were created
by Tesla designer Drew Prasad a senior
designer at liquid Inc design who touted
it as Tesla's next big thing he comments
that the Tesla Model Y Yacht is all
about exploration and when you look at
what the yacht has to offer that's
pretty easy to see but here's the kicker
Elon Musk Tesla CEO has had nothing to
do with the project and has never
publicly backed it still fans are
eagerly anticipating the project hoping
that the company will back it and make
it a reality I mean if Elon Musk can
successfully send Rockets into space and
create humanoid robots surely he can
make the model Y super yacht happen
right while there's still no official
release date from Tesla one thing is for
sure this super yacht price tag will
make it a luxury item for only the most
affluent individuals so if you're a fan
of Tesla's Innovative and sustainable
designs and can afford to splurge on a
super yacht keep your eyes peeled for
the model Y super yacht the next big
thing in Ocean Travel as I've already
mentioned this electric yacht could as
well be a fever dream because there is
no concrete proof that it started being
produced but then again this is Elon
Musk it could all be done underground
with him surprising us one day and
disrupting the market well Tesla is not
the only business that's going green on
the yacht there are businesses such as
Alva yacht the Kevin Durant Will Smith
and Sean Diddy back startup Arc boats
and the Revolutionary solar-powered
silent with these you can see that the
concept of electric Yachts is fast
growing and more sustainable forms of
energy are being found so it's no
surprise that Tesla is looking to be at
the Forefront because if they're known
for one thing it's being crazy
Innovative thanks for watching click on
the videos you see on your screens and
I'll show you more crazy Tech stuff